I do want to take a moment now before
you proceed with the show to mention a
very special charity and this is
important it's called night of too many
stars this is a big deal
that of too many stairs stars is an
event that raises funds to build schools
programs and services to help the
growing population of autistic people
who desperately need them now this is
gonna air on Comedy Central
this Sunday October 21st at 8 o'clock
p.m. and all the biggest celebrities are
helping out it's hosted by Jon Stewart
Tina Fey is gonna be there Katy Perry
Amy Poehler Stephen Colbert louis c.k Al
Pacino showing up Wow
that's just the tip of the iceberg and
it's gonna be an amazing amazing event
and this this whole night of too many
stores started by our good friend Robert
Smigel right and for a number of years
we've been helping out in different ways
this year I wanted to sort of up the
ante because I wanted to do my part but
I wanted to to raise it to the next
level so here's the plan and I'm
absolutely serious about this if we can
raise over $100,000 by Sunday night when
night of too many stars airs I will do
an entire episode of my show with a deep
full spray tan
and this is real okay now what do you
say fool do you mean everything or just
two parts of the show free thing almost
everything
we'll see okay anyway it's a once in a
lifetime chance to see me with some
coloring in my skin yeah this is
historic so if you want to make two
dreams happen one building schools and
programs for autistic individuals and to
seeing me look like a member of the
Jersey Shore cast with acute hepatitis
you've got to do this please donate what
you can
at teen koco.com / - many stars or you
can text to donate $10 $10 just by
texting the word conan to five oh five
five five this is important you are a
hero well no actually I'm not Andy I
want to point this out I am NOT a hero
there's in fact a long tradition of talk
show hosts doing noble stunts like this
for charity for example one time you
probably remember this a couple years
ago Oprah Winfrey shaved her head into a
lightening bolt for charity yeah once
her charity Regis Philbin was buried up
to his neck in an anthill and they just
left him there Wow and of course
everyone remembers the time Joan Rivers
appeared without makeup this
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you yes oh good we're doing so
once again to help this great cause and
see me with a deep rich sexy spray tan
for an entire hour of this show donate
what you can at Team Coco calm slash too
many stars or donate ten dollars by
texting the word Conan to 5:05
[Applause]